hey guys i'm philip molina and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 6
episode 3 Oathbreaker and there were a
lot of loaded scenes to explain and
there's actually so many deep theories
to untangle and I feel like this episode
I noticed tons of little things like
more than normal so let's just get
started with the opening images the
episode opens on a black void but we
hear heavy breathing over we're kind of
like Aria trying to make sense of the
sound while not having vision to rely on
but then also like Aria in this episode
we regain our sight and we see both
Davos and John are breathing very
heavily it's interesting that the man
who's shocked by what it just happened
is breathing just as hard as a man who
just came back to life now aside from
the Arya foreshadowing there's another
point of significance to starting in
this Dark Void when John is asked after
you died why did you go where he went
and death what was there for him he said
he saw on the other side no warm light
no naked angel Ygritte no icy hell with
naked blond-haired white walkers just
blackness nothing so this opening image
is a taste of that nothing that Jon Snow
knows so well
also this vaguely reminded me of The
Simpsons because of what John says and
how he and Flanders both feel like
they're wearing nothing at all nothing
at all nothing at all stupid sexy
Flanders if you're wondering why Jon
Snow seen nothing after death doesn't
disappoint Melisandre it actually kind
of makes sense since the people who
follow the Lord of Light believe that
hell is currently taking place on earth
and that the heavenly afterlife is only
earned after you serve the Lord of Light
something that John still hasn't
technically done and I got to point out
technically yet because it's looking
pretty solid that as Melisandre says
John will be the prophesied prince that
was promised I went into all of that in
the last video with some pleasantly
pleasing prince that was promised
prophecy Peele iteration so I check that
video out a few huh more details on what
this deal is the princess promise but
let's keep going Oh though before we
move on I want to point out one more
thing despite the fact that this was
definitely a team effort
Davos shoes Melisandre out of the room
in
way that's a good reminder he does not
trust her he still hasn't forgotten how
she led Stannis and Shireen to their
doom or he might not even know that yet
but he knows something bad there
happened I feel like there's conflict
between them that's still you have to
come now moving on we get a little bit
more of these Christ parallels as
everyone stares in awe at this godly
figure John emerging from his barricaded
room like Jesus emerging from his
barricaded tomb and torment even calls
out that people think he's a god and if
you think about it it's kind of lucky
that these people are impressed by this
resurrection since there is another way
they could have interpreted it which is
what dolorous EDD is hinting at I should
still drown he's concerned that it could
be the same magic he witnessed at
hardhome that brought back the dead and
that magic results in the spooky blue
eyes so it's a valid legit concerning as
I'm moving on as Sam and Gilly cross the
stormy seas Gilly tells us kind of
charming kind of embarrassing story
about how she used to think the ocean
was called the sea because it's nothing
but water as far as the eye can see on
the surface this is just Gilly admitting
she's not good with words but the idea
of venturing into a great unknown the
ocean that spans out as far as the eye
can see that's a big metaphorical deal
for Gilly remember this is the same
woman who did not want to name her baby
before he was like three years old cuz
she thought he might die so she's been
so terrified to look forward that she
was only willing to live life probably
one terrible day at a time now she's
finally excited by what the future has
in store for her and she has no idea
what that is
all she knows is that the possibilities
are endless and they go as far as the
eye can see also want to point out here
that Sam is kind of breaking his oath to
Gilly he told her he'd always go
wherever she goes and I talked a lot
about oath breaking in the last episode
and how it caused a lot of the problems
that these characters have found
themselves in but those are Oats broken
for pride and greed however like Gilly
admits she knows this oath breaking is
for the greater good
that is very different and something
that comes up a lot of times this
episode I'll call them out as we go now
moving on to the famous Tower of joy
scene that I was very pumped about last
video I kind of explained why this
flashback was important last episode but
just some quick other details to point
out here so for context King Robert his
rebellion has just ended and he's
was taking the throne Robert has just
sent Ned Stark to go find Ned sister
Lyanna but more importantly to Robert
she's also the woman that he's supposed
to marry his betrothed they hear that
she might be at this Tower of joy which
by the way this is actually Northern
Dorne that we're in right now and so
they go there to find out what's up so
when you take a look at these two guys
guarding this tower those helmets look
familiar and their chest blades have
Targaryen symbols on them and that's
because they're the Kingsguard of that
time at least two of the Kingsguard in
the books it's three of them but now we
know that this guy that brand points out
is the big red ibly badass sword of the
morning Arthur Dayne basically he's like
the Bruce Lee of knights but the other
guy it's not as clear who he is but
there's this really hard to see bat on
his helm that points out he's probably
Oswald went of house went that's their
sigil another interesting thing to note
is that Ned kills him in a moment and
it's unclear in the books of the show
how exactly but this guy's actually kind
of a relative of Catelyn Stark's so huh
sorry Catelyn now fighting alongside Ned
we've got a couple of his homeboys
though the only one that is really worth
pointing out can be recognized by his
house sigil of the lizard lion which is
basically just a giant alligator and
that's Howland Reed Meera and Jojen dad
he's known for eating frogs that's true
also he's known for having saved Ned in
his battle though if you read Ned space
you realize it's not the kind of saving
that he has a lot of respect for dabbing
the sword of the morning in the back
like that is actually pretty honorless
in Ned's eyes this is why he gives them
a more fitting warriors death a moment
later and also why according to the
books Ned picks up Arthur Dayne sword
and takes it back to deliver it to the
Dane family by the way that is a very
epic sword it's called dawn and you can
see on the hilt as a symbol of a star
that's because it's supposedly made from
a part of a fallen star and it's also
like light saber sharp Arthur Dayne
actually used that sword tonight Jamie
Lannister and it said that when he did
it when he touched his sword to his
shoulder it somehow
I was the only cut through all of his
clothes and cut through his skin like a
drew blood by accident that's how sharp
that sword is oh and while we are on the
topic of swords I'll point out that this
sword that Ned is fighting with it's
actually not his famous Valyrian steel
sword ice this actually seems to be the
same or the same kind of longsword that
he used back in season one
he also is dressing basically the same
outfits he wears in season one though
he's actually not the only person that
ends up rocking a similar look to this
in this episode but we will get back to
that so if you're wondering why er
Kingsguard guarding some random tower in
the middle of Dorne especially when
their king has just been killed and his
son Rhaegar has also just been killed
that's a great question and one that
adds a lot of fuel to some theories the
only person that could be worthy of
Kingsguard protection in this moment is
another member of the royal family and
that would mean that inside that tower
is probably regards new son who was
described in Daenerys his vision from
the books as the prince that was
promised does that sound familiar it
should in that vision Rhaegar also says
about his son that his is the Song of
Ice and Fire
which makes sense of his dad is Rhaegar
a fiery Targaryen and his mom is Liana
and I see Winterfell
it's also interesting that I bring up
Jamie here because this is right after
Jamie has broken his oath and killed the
Mad King instead of protecting him
that's very much in contrast to the two
men that stand here both Ned Stark and
Arthur Dayne are very famous for their
honour and that makes a promise after
the Tower of joy to Liana that he never
will break and Arthur is doing his
Kingsguard promise duty here in this
moment even though he knows it probably
means is that these are two guys who
really respect oats but they're also
both dead now and we'll get back to that
later but there is another really
interesting thing about the fact that
they bring up Jaime here this entire
fight mirrors Ned Stark's fight with
Jaime way back in season one both fights
start with a confrontation about a
missing sibling where's my sister I'm
looking for my brother then in both
fights Ned Stark is totally outmatched
in a sword fight with a member of the
Kingsguard who uses two blades and then
in both fights when that is about to
possibly be killed someone unhhhh
ceremoniously stabbed somebody else it
from the back and the fight is over
compared Ned and Jamie's reaction in
those moments to know this is even more
obscene when you realize that in the
books after Ned and Jamie have this
fight Ned gets super sick from his
injuries and he takes a bunch of milk of
the puppy and it makes him have these
fever dreams that in those fever dreams
what does he have a flashback to this
other exact fight with Sir Arthur Dayne
at the Tower of joy so they're purposely
mirrored and linked fights then we get
kind of blue balled by the three-eyed
Raven
what's in the tower that's enough for
one day though that seems pretty obvious
what's happening there those screams
kind of sound like childbirth maybe but
the part I'm more curious about is one
brand shouts out to Ned in the past and
that hears him
that's huge the three-eyed Raven says
don't worry about that you can't affect
the past it's already written but what
if it's not or fine what if it is
but what if bran has always been part of
what has happened kind of like how Harry
Potter uses the time Turner and Harry
warns himself before we actually ever
even see him go back in time that means
that Harry always affected the timeline
no matter what and so maybe Ned Stark
always heard bran sane but why is that
important well theory time here first if
bran has always been involved in the
path and has always had an affect on it
what else might have cause some people
think that it's possible that bran tried
to communicate with King Aerys and these
whispers might be what actually drove
him into becoming the Mad King others
think what if brand tried to warg into
Willis and that's what messed up his
brain so he can only say Hodor
I think that's all really interesting
also though the other version where bran
might be able to newly affect the past
that's interesting too because what if
he changes things I think this show is
pretty great right but adding time
travel to the mix is it's like they want
me to marry it anyway before we move on
I just want to point out that the
three-eyed Raven implies that he's been
in that tree for a thousand years you
think I wanted to sit here for a
thousand years remember last week I said
that I heard a rumor the show might not
go into his backstory this might be
confirmation of that because in the
books like I said in the other video he
actually has a story very clear about
being a pretty normal guy at one point
named Brendan rivers but Brendan
definitely isn't a thousand years old so
maybe it's not him on the show maybe
they're changing that the only other
thing I think is maybe the essence of
the three-eyed Raven has been in this
tree for a thousand years but it only
took over the body of Brendan rivers
more recently okay let's move on if you
paid close attention to the opening
credits you knew we were gonna see
another city bias doth rack that's the
dothraki home city where all the former
wives of the calls have to go retire
we saw it in season one actually when
Danny ate that horse cart and also since
that's the city that forbids weapons
it's also where Khal Drogo had to kill
Viserys by giving them a golden crown
better than a golden shower
something interesting to point out here
is we get this shot of this horse whole
right we know horses are sacred to the
Dothraki and they have a prophecy about
the stallion who will mount the world it
sounds kind of similar to the zora high
prince I was promised prophecy and I
wouldn't be surprised if they were
actually connected prophecies because
the scene that we just saw right before
this that's also probably about the
birth of the Prince I was promised that
scene also starts with a shot of horse
hoofs I don't think that's a coincidence
and the importance of this horse image
is really cemented when you see how
carefully design this shot is with the
statue in the foreground and you notice
in the background it's like glowing halo
kind of around is teeny-tiny Daenerys
it's clear that she's at a low right now
walking amongst a death racki like their
lower level people who are denied horses
but I have a feeling that this glowing
here is foreshadowing how she's gonna
rise up in this community once more I
just don't know how yet we actually get
a lot more foreshadowing of Daenerys 'iz
latent potential power in the very next
scene this is actually kind of a long
bit here but it's very worth it so pay
attention here she enters the Great
Temple at the heart of the city and
there's a moment where she loses her
clothes and notice how the camera cuts
away it's clear that neither Danny or
Emilia Clarke wants to be I make it in
this moment but it's interesting when
you remember the last time Danny was
naked in front of the Dothraki it was
this huge moment of power for her which
feels like maybe the opposite of this
moment except I think it's not the
opposite here I think this moment is
supposed to mirror that moment and even
as Danny is being talked down to work
for shadowing her latent power that is
Targaryen fire simmering let me explain
why I think this on a show like this
whenever you see this much fire
especially when an actor actress is
wielding the fire it's a very big deal
they have to be doing that on purpose
there's often stunt coordinators
involved the fire marshals usually on
set it's definitely something they only
do when it's very important to them that
we see this fire in this shot so okay so
that's one thing clearly the fire is
important but then
the design of these shots the cameras
and the director go out of their way to
make sure that Danny's body never
completely blocks the image of fire but
instead have the fire flickering through
her hair visually reminding us that she
is the unburnt one and that fire does
not hurt her and if you think that I'm
talking out of my ass and that this
framing is just a coincidence I'm gonna
point out that the director was so
obsessed with getting this shot right
designed that exact way that it doesn't
even keep good continuity when we go to
a reverse angle the older woman flips
from being on Danny's right to being on
her left so again I'm telling you
they're doing this on purpose and if you
actually follow Danny's eyes it might
initially seem like she's looking at the
old woman but she's actually looking the
other direction she's staring into that
fire then when the woman crosses in
front of her through her view Danny
really blatantly looks away from her to
keep staring into the flames and then
finally this isn't cemented hard enough
for you as being an indicator that when
Danny's in a room surrounded by torches
that actually represents her own in her
strength then watched this cut and
listened to the sound of the torches
burning as we go directly into Danny's
other place of power
her current throne and the torches are
surround her there okay I think I hit
that hard enough but I will also just
point out that this older ladies beef
with Danny it's because she's just
another one of these people that is
breaking one of these kind of lame oats
but it's for the greater good she didn't
go live out her days envious dothraki
she went on a noble mission instead
she's been breaking chains and stuff
it's stuff that she believes is the
right thing to do so I hope you're
keeping count on these people that are
breaking the oaths for good reasons but
yeah moving to that scene in marine 2
things have note here this is the first
time that I can think of that we've
actually seen how Varys really does his
work he obviously proscribed by the idea
of getting more flies with honey than
with vinegar his honey ears are
presented by this bag of silver which in
itself is representative of the famous
silver that was offered to another
person who was asked to betray the head
of their faith
Judas accepted silver to betray Jesus
just like valla here is accepting silver
to betray the heartbeat and Barrett's
his offer works really well here which
is married a moment later when qui Bern
uses the childhood version of silver
sweets to entice varys's little birds
which by the way have finally been
revealed
being just [ __ ] little children's
sweets and silver seem to be as
effective as fire and steel can be also
I just want to point out this object
that this little girl is playing with
that's an armillary sphere or a
spherical astrolabe and if it feels
familiar that's because you see it every
episode the Rings float above the map of
the title sequence and this item is
known as a symbol for a few things one
it's a representative of global
domination which is clearly what Game of
Thrones is all about but it's also a
representation of the Sun hovering above
the lands of man and along with that Sun
imagery comes the other really common
meaning of these actual aids
they often represent the idea that the
gods are actually in charge of what
happens on earth often you see the titan
god atlas holding one up sometimes it's
other gods sometimes it's even the
Chinese dragon deities holding one out
so the titles show the game board with
the pieces being established with men as
the pond and the actual players are the
gods above and I think that is why we
haven't even seen the freaking throne
room in multiple seasons have you
noticed that it's just not as important
anymore in this larger game that the
gods are playing and if that's too
flowery for you I also point out that I
just love how the mountains ability to
smash heads is something that Jamie has
realized is his go-to move chillin to
march into the Sept and crush the high
sparrows head like a man I mean we have
seen him do it twice and the rule of
threes tells us that another head
smashing is probably coming oh speaking
of the head smashing II's e to miss
moment qui burn ask the kid about his
father that was beating him your father
no one's seen him another one and it's
pretty likely that the way quite burned
dealt with his father and why no one has
seen or heard from the father is because
that's whose head got smashed last
episode it also would explain how word
got back to Cersei and circle again that
this guy was telling these stories about
her his son happens to be a little bird
for them also the kid and the guy look a
lot alike or they used to before the
head smashing now moving on I just want
to point out Tyrians introduction to a
new style political strategy well at
least it's new to marine and to Masson
day and to grey worm Narus has gotten a
lot through force and that's the only
thing that these two know as well but I
think we're seeing more of Tyrians
wisdom being foreshadowed here with that
quote about great
stations and elegant rooms the true
history of the world is a history of
great conversations in elegant rooms
I think Tyrion is going to bring
conversation meaning negotiation style
governing to this place but I got a
wonder if they're gonna accept that fare
remember people like ilaria Searcy and
Olli are out there in this world and
they hate when you use logic rather than
violence to settle a matter of vengeance
so what side will the people marine fall
on I wonder a bit later Tommen finally
stands up to the high Sparrow what kind
of stands up to him when Tom and shouts
I am The King that's a parallel to a
moment of weakness for the last King
because as Tywin taught Joffrey any man
who must say I am the king is no true
king interesting to note that Tommen
like Joffrey is actually not a true King
because he's not really a Baratheon so
Tywin is literally right about that by
the way this exploiting of us bad knee
and this in-your-face humility of I'm
not wearing shoes this guy is obviously
a master manipulator and just like
Tyrion Varys and quite burn he's showing
us just one more way to get what you
want in contrast to the violence and so
many others prefer this is just his
method it's his game strategy and it
makes me actually not really trust this
guy I mean like I'm not wearing shoes
right now
come on moving on then like the opening
images foreshadow just like we did Arya
goes from blind to seeing and it's after
this training montage that really work
for me actually they snuck in this
really cool Easter egg in the direction
and editing of this moment check it out
as the waif is asking Arya to tell her
the stories of her past and her family
the beatings that she receives actually
reflect the person of whom are if speaks
so when she says robbed the wave shots
the arm and torso like the arrows that
hit robbed when she says bran the wave
strikes at areas back dropping her to
her hands representing brands paralysis
and when the wave pass tell me about how
she and Arya actually have this pretty
equally mad fighter a few hits at least
just like Brean and the hounded before
the wave stands Arya falling backwards
just like Brienne sent the Hound falling
backwards now the only thing that's
scary about this is that the weight also
struck at Arya's leg when she said
Rickon but since I think this was all
deaf
early on purpose it makes me worry about
what's gonna happen to richens leg and
moving on to Rick in situation in
general we were right
he was the gift to Ramsey that we
predicted last episode and there's this
an interesting parallel line that
describes his predicament Ramsey tells
Rickon welcome that's just like the call
telling Danny abolish both of these
welcomes are totally false and it's a
continuation of last episodes theme
these homes that these characters are
returning to they're more like prisons
if you haven't checked out the last
video by the way they really like nailed
that idea of home as a prison that you
have to leave before you can return to
it it's really interesting but check
that one out for that oh and by the way
man the gut punch that you feel when you
see this severed head of richens
direwolf shaggy-dog dropping on the
table now assuming that that's really
Shaggy dog's head this actually was
predicted by shaggy dog's name a couple
of videos ago I gave you a recap as to
how the different dire wolf names
represent the stark children and they
predict the stark children stories by
the way some of you fought me on the
idea that gray wins name is a reference
to but in the books you read again and
again that men consider oaths to be just
words and in the phrase words are wind
gets said like a hundred times so I
stand by that idea that gray wind is a
reference to gray oats but one
connection that I did not make because
it was gonna bum me out
but now it looks like it might have come
true anyway it's shaggy dog's name so
you see a shaggy dog story it's actually
a screenwriting term that refers to a
story that seems like it's really headed
somewhere really interesting it's got
all these twists and turns instead of
having some great payoff it actually
ends in a kind of pointless way often
just like a pointless death and nothing
really important comes out of it so the
way that Rickon has been missing all
this time and we've wondered what could
that mean was he starting a new Stark
army was he recruited by the White
Walkers what's been going on with him
well it kind of looks like just nothing
was going on with him he's just back as
a prisoner of Winterfell again almost
like he never left at all and so the
story of his direwolf well it didn't
really go anywhere either
that's kind of a dick move actually by
george RR martin if that is the case but
he did literally name the wolf after the
idea of a story like that unless this is
a huge mystery like we're meant to think
that this is just a shaggy dog story but
actually it could be
hugely important plot point because what
if that's not shaggy dogs head let's
activate theory mode a lot of people
thought the head looked a little small
for a direwolf and that may or may not
be true but it kind of looks true when
you compare it to grey winds head but
more importantly why would there be a
fake-out head well did you notice the
way Lord umber refused to kneel or swear
loyalty to Ramsay traditionally about a
man kneels before his lord not doing
that either could it be because he's
actually not loyal to Ramsay but it's
actually still loyal to the Starks the
North remembers and if Rickon has just
been a guest of house umber this whole
time and then he's just turned him over
to Ramsey that would be a betrayal of
the protection provided to guests just
like what happened at the red wedding
which is what the north is supposed to
be remembering so either this is a
brilliant plan by the umbers to
undermine the Bolton hold of Winterfell
or they're all dicks and if that's the
case I really hope that shaggy dog took
a bunch of members down with him oh also
I know that the actor that plays Rick
Cohen said that he thinks it is a shaggy
dogs head you might be right but still
if we were also told that Jon Snow was
definitely dead and probably not coming
back so the actors might not know or
they might not be allowed to talk about
it I still think there's some
possibility so theory yeah we're
starting to wrap things up so let's keep
going John examines his best with all
these stab cuts in it and he's still
blown away that his body received those
same wounds and those wounds will never
heal by the way it's a reminder of the
betrayal that leads to this execution a
moment later by the way these are
probably the lead conspirators that he's
hanging here as they're all in positions
of power Bowen Marsh was the first
Seward yarwyck it was the first builder
thorne the first ranger Ali first
punk-ass [ __ ] haha or maybe it's
because he was the one that straight-up
lied to him it's one of the wildlings
she brought back cuz he knows your Uncle
Benjen says he's still alive actually I
know we all hated Ollie but it's really
tough to see a kid dies in it like no
matter how terrible he was except
Joffrey that that was just great now the
one thing I want to point out about this
execution though is actually sir thorns
last words you defied nettles forever
this mirrors the moments before sir
Danes execution by Ned Stark I wish you
could put you in the wars to come these
are two Knights who happen to find
themselves on the wrong side of history
they both true
we believe that they're doing what's
right and they both predict that these
men who are left behind you're gonna
have many battles I had for years to
come so it's an interesting parallel and
just like his father John swings his
sword of justice himself and then we go
into our closing images remember all
this episode began with Davos throwing a
cloak over John that immediate wrapping
of John and a Night's Watch cloak
represents John being trapped by his
Night's Watch vows but here in the end
of the episode John throws off his Lord
Commander cloak he's rejecting those
vows he's abandoning his post and giving
Deloris edie command of Castle black by
the way that does not make ed the new
Lord Commander he's just an interim
leader until they vote again yeah either
way John straight-up quits he's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so that adds John to the
list of characters who are bending or
breaking their oath this episode to
potentially follow a path for a greater
good now I feel like this episode is
purposely paired with the last episode
to illustrate the difference between
breaking oaths for one's own fortune or
for straight up evil reasons like Ramsey
vs. these people who have bent or broken
their oaths for the greater good
Daenerys Sam John also they have to do
in order to survive in this world of
evil man remember I pointed out earlier
that Ned and Arthur are both dead
because they couldn't back down from
their oaths they're too honorable to
live in this world well if every hero
was a hundred percent beholden to their
oaths and just stuck with them and they
don't be dead to the bad guys would win
this world needs evolved heroes who
knows that they have to bend the rules
to survive but only if it's for the
greater good but when noble men are
breaking these oaths they still feel all
the guilt because they don't know that
they're right like for Jon Snow being an
Oathbreaker here is really hard for him
to swallow
keep in mind ever since he took the
black in season one he's made all his
decisions in the context of whether or
not he's being loyal to his oath as a
brother of the Nights Watch killing the
half pan joining the wildlings loving
Ygritte putting Mance Rayder out of his
misery
saving the wildlings from heart home
each of these hard choices made him
question whether or not he's actually
doing the right thing if he's being a
loyal guy and the fear of being
considered an Oathbreaker has haunted
him every time so it's become something
he's scared of but now that he died and
came back he's right his watch has ended
but that doesn't mean that he knows that
he's in the right all of those terrible
experiences he's had have stripped him
of his motivation and his sense
dooty obviously he doesn't feel duty to
the Nights Watch anymore and he
shouldn't since he left Winterfell he's
fought again and again and he keeps
losing something every time he does so
he probably doesn't know what to fight
for if he wants to ever fight again and
note actually even though he just quit
his job he's actually walking away from
the entrance to Castle black so he's
clearly still very aimless he doesn't
know what he's gonna do and that is why
I'm hoping that he feels that pull that
I talked about in the last episode I
think whether or not he knows it as he's
passing through a tunnel here
symbolically leaving the wall behind him
the time has come for him to return home
to Winterfell I mentioned earlier that
someone else was dressing like Ned Stark
and here he is come on Jon like you you
least subconsciously know that you have
to go back there so please go kick
Ramsay's ass it's such a frustrating
shame you can tell his will is broken
right he's so sick of having to fight
these battles but actually what this
episode teaches us is this only if he
decides to do what he needs to do taking
on a noble cause probably go kick ass at
Winterfell it's the only scenario that
makes this oath breaking okay because
yes I'm calling it just like Danny broke
her Oh to the Dothraki for a noble
reason and Sam broke his promise to
Gilly to take her to safety Jon actually
must he's required to take on a new
noble cause and I think it's only gonna
come from teaming up with Sansa Brienne
and Brian's Oathkeeper does Jon Snow get
to be guilt free and forgiven by the
gods for now becoming an Oathbreaker
so lingering questions a one time travel
stuff do you think that Ned really heard
bran in that moment in the flashback if
so do you think it means that Brant can
change the past or that bran already did
and always had change the past
if you don't get that question do not
worry time-travel stuff is weird too do
you think I'm right about Jon needing to
go to Winterfell to truly be guilt-free
for leaving the Nights Watch
or do you think there's some other
journey out there for him I had three
the umbers and the shaggy dog theory
what say you is Lord umber plain Ramsay
or is it recipe shaggy-dog
I'll be honest I think it probably is
shaggy dog's head just because of the
name thing I mentioned before but it
could still be part of some larger plan
though if it's not a trick then I'm
really worried about Rickon based on
shaggy dogs fate also I hate to say it
but knowing Ramsay's track record with
women Oh
is like as good as dead right like I
hope not but I do not have a good
feeling for her all right let me know
answers to all those in the comments I
also if you like these videos please
share them share them spread them into
the wild subscribe to new rockstars to
keep up with them if any points deserve
talking to me about you can tweet at me
at female but if you need a longer
discussion hit me up over on my Facebook
page it's facebook.com slash fimo nose
we can have a little bit longer
discussions there and if you have any
questions about stuff I talked about
from the other videos make sure to go
watch those or just keep a lookout for
our next video and the next episode is
book of the stranger should be
interesting but otherwise I'm all done
here I'll see you next time bye